[Music]
so
speaking of uh dentists during a dental
procedure a drill bit that disappeared
into the mouth of a patient was actually
inhaled huh
how did they just disappear so they're
working on they're working on this guy's
teeth yeah
the drill bit
disappears where'd it go and the dude
that's me dude he literally just sucked
it into his lungs
oh oh he breathed it all he did was
cough and and didn't know where like
didn't even like choke or anything he
just went
and that's it and then he was like oh
and then the dentist is like i think
it's in i think you've just
breathed that in
isn't that important
i never thought that could ever happen i
never thought it could happen either i
never thought it could just go in your
lung and you wouldn't just instantly die
was it like a tip it's an inch
an inch
so it's long
yeah inch long is that like this they're
pretty [ __ ]
yeah they're super they're really thin
so you probably just want an
i injury show you half an inch is that
cool
not a full inch
he wasn't in pain or like no that's the
weirdest [ __ ] yeah so he was getting his
tooth filled
and he said he says i didn't even really
feel it go down all i felt was a cough
when they did the ct scan they realized
he thought he swallowed it but then when
they scanned it they realized that he
inhaled it
how are they going to get it out well
they saw it in his lungs in the ct scan
yeah god
in his lung like in it yeah and they
said that uh this is it this is going to
cut up his lungs it's in kenosha in
wisconsin as they thought they would
have to do they were like hey the bit is
so deep that the normal scope can't
reach it or did he cough and shoot it
back out
like a cartoon they just licked him
now they said uh they might have to take
part of his lung out but when they tried
to remove the object they were able to
perfectly take it out without touching
any of his like vital stuff
and it flew in yeah [ __ ] magic school
bus
they just got misfrizzled got in there
this is when you need that medical
insurance man
how much is how much is that without
[ __ ] i don't even want to freaking
well that is gonna stay in my lungs i
better cover that dude imagine that
dentist office work 50 grand or 100
grand or some [ __ ] have you guys had any
major surgery
knock on wood not yet yeah i mean pretty
much oh i know yours yeah i don't mind
already
yeah
de-bald i got de-bulk easiest thing i
ever got was just a root canal
oh you never got your wisdom teeth taken
that was well the mind's still in there
yeah mine are hanging on i just don't
understand how the did the so the drill
they didn't say how it came off of the
tool
like aren't those supposed to be pretty
secure maybe he didn't [ __ ] tighten
it tight enough you're quite [ __ ] up
how do you type like a [ __ ] power
tool guys
i have my tier list of power tools
you know like the [ __ ] drill you just
put that [ __ ] on and sometimes it just
falls out ah [ __ ] you gotta put it back
down yeah that was me yesterday i was
trying to [ __ ] do a drill bit kept
falling out except except in this case
you're doing oral whole [ __ ] surgery
you you think you'd be even more careful
one of those days he has tools and they
have the
the guy goes under like a car yeah
that's going to be way better it's like
rolling around like this
you're just drooling all over them
panic you're like this yeah the dentist
has to wear the bib
yeah mix them up
he's like oh this doesn't look good
that'd be way better it wouldn't have
fallen in the mouth
just a big face
it falls in the dentist's mouth yeah
cause he's gotta do it like this
now we gotta switch places
it was always gonna be one of us
hey you just put your face to like the
massage table like this oh
smart
[Laughter]
how we doing today wait so what can you
inhale without dying then
this dude that's why this guy was 60
he's 60 years old
he must have some freaking daddy deep
throat lungs
for real
i'm like how did that fall through like
[ __ ] operation and didn't go
like that's pretty impressive man
the deep throat king that's the thorough
what does he look like do you have a
picture yeah he looks like johnny sins
no there's no picture
there's no photo of him
yeah but that's pretty crazy that he
said he really said all he felt was a
cough you know when you're about to
cough and you like inhale real quick wow
that's what he did and that's when he
went
probably like swallowing a vitamin raw
yeah dude he probably never [ __ ]
really even swallowed you ever swallowed
an ice cube raw an accident yeah oh yeah
no how did you do that accident you're
just gulping and just you talking too
much while you have ice in your mouth oh
is that like when you're when you're
tilting the cup and then all the ice
cream
yeah yeah they're waiting until you hit
it really hard and it all goes down your
mouth and you [ __ ] feel it right here
the worst is the first time you you
swallow seawater on accident oh yeah all
the salt yeah it just goes if it goes in
your nose [ __ ] and then you get like the
saltiest burp come out maybe like a
piece of [ __ ] you're like an idiot
yourself yeah yeah yeah i like to gargle
with seawater
you guys remember the
the water's only salty because it's
whale's [ __ ] myth you guys ever heard of
it
yeah now that's science i think
bill nye was like no it's true i thought
all salt is [ __ ]
[Laughter]
bleach all the time
is that right is that a myth too
bro at this point i don't know if it's
real or not
i think it might be cooler if it's real
though
we're swimming in welcome see swallowing
i mean anytime you're swimming anywhere
there's got to be at least a little [ __ ]
there's a little come everywhere
especially the store you told about your
homie who is in the ice cream any sample
size that a scientist looks like because
there it is
it's like the cocaine with the dollar
theory you know it's like they say
there's always a little speck of cocaine
on every dollar right what is that about
there's no way that's
we tried to convince the world of that
it's just one guy that said it it's
probably the guy that got caught with
the substance on his hands and he was
like guys every dollar all the dollars
yeah they're all like this
tell us the cops hey did you know
there's a little cocaine and the cops go
what
no way you're innocent yeah yeah
this guy's freaked out
like the jury goes
oh
everyone pulls out their wallet
the lawyers like
right yeah
right everyone pulls out their wallets
just snow
it's like a magic trick now check your
wallet
you're all under arrest
including me
bailiff arrest the jury
[Laughter]
hey you got a
there's a little bit of cocaine in all
of our buddies i know i mean that
definitely probably was true maybe in
the 80s maybe maybe yeah but i think
people still do a lot of cooking
yeah yeah
still miami to this day
yeah but at least with this guy at least
they were able to catch it because he
seemed like he didn't have any
discomfort imagine if
you swallowed a drill bit and you just
went through life like my ex did with
the condom interview when you cough and
you get internal bleeding is there
anything bigger than a hundred dollar
bill
was there ever a five hundred dollars
there was but they used it mainly to
transport currency and not to actually
spend it oh okay yeah it was a way of
being able to like move money around
who's the president
i don't know [ __ ] abraham lincoln
again
you ever have lincoln with a mustache
because that one's fine return
engagement on the thousand dollar bills
just like this oh
because it's 500 right so then it's like
five
i know they had like thousand something
and ten thousands they did
yeah but it wasn't for the public as
well
yeah it was yeah it was like to move
money back in the day so you didn't have
to get robbed carrying a [ __ ]
truckload of [ __ ] dollar coins because
otherwise that's going on a wagon it's
very visible right it's like
transferring yeah was there ever any
doubt i remember we were supposed to get
rid of pennies like five years ago yeah
they keep saying that they keep saying
that they never have pennies oh yeah
there was a thousand dollar bill stopped
in 1969 nice isn't that crazy that it
costs money to transport money like you
have to spend money to transport money
you know that's like the fees of like
if i'm sending money
there's a fee but all they could have
done that [ __ ] for free i like the
paypal fees like what do you guys do
like a bank wire transfer right that
[ __ ] is if you think about it i think
it's way too damn much to charge 25 on a
bank transfer because
now everything is on [ __ ] digital so
like before it made sense where it's
like okay you have to transfer the
[ __ ] tube or whatever yeah there's
like someone has to run the [ __ ]
money but now it's just you click it and
it just goes to your account and they're
charging you money for that [ __ ] that's
crazy that build looks dude check this
out so they did have a ten thousand
dollar bill the guy on it was salmon p
chase who was the secretary of the
treasury under abraham his name was
salmon salmon p chase after chase bank
i mean but the
you know the chase bank that was that
was a guy's name i think
come on and then there was a hundred
thousand dollar bill
and it was actually uh halibut
halibut morgan
from jpmorgan chase
halibut morgan
halibut morgan nice to meet you
what a [ __ ] dumb halibut morgan
captain halibut morgan
a little bit more
it's from jb morgan and that was how jp
morgan chase was started dude
oh my god
this is stupid that [ __ ] jp tuna
[Music]
i